aquí nos dan un sistema de ecuaciones y
nos piden resolver para x y lo más fácil
de hacer aquí
dado que en ambas ecuaciones está la y
ya despejada es considerar que bien
sigue es igual a esto y esto calle es
igual a esto otro esto entonces no queda
de otra más que estas dos expresiones
sean iguales esto es sigue es igual a
esta expresión que tenemos aquí y tengo
que encontrar xy que cumplan con las dos
ecuaciones porque no sustituir entonces
el valor de ye que conocemos de la
primera ecuación en esta segunda
ecuación de tal manera que esta segunda
ecuación se convierte en el lado
izquierdo es menos un cuarto de x más
100 y esto es igual a a esto que tenemos
aquí lo voy a poner en el mismo color
menos un cuarto de x
+ 120 ahora lo siguiente que podemos
hacer es llevar los términos en x de un
solo lado de la ecuación así es que para
deshacernos de este término en x del
lado derecho lo más fácil es sumar un
cuarto de x a ambos lados de la ecuación
hagamos eso sumando entonces un cuarto
de x del lado derecho y sumamos un
cuarto de x del lado derecho lo más
seguro es que ya te diste cuenta que
algo muy extraño está sucediendo aquí
hacemos la suma menos un cuarto de x más
un cuarto de x es igual a cero los
términos en x se cancelan por lo cual
sólo nos queda 100 y esto es igual a lo
mismo menos un cuarto de x más un cuarto
de x también es cero por lo cual
únicamente nos queda del lado derecho
120 pero hemos obtenido entonces algo
que sabemos que no es posible 100 no es
igual a 120 esto es una contradicción al
haber obtenido esto sin sentido podemos
concluir entonces que este sistema de
ecuaciones no tiene solución
solución si hubiera alguna solución
estos dos números tendrían que ser
iguales sin embargo no son iguales y si
observamos con cuidado las ecuaciones
originales se nos podría ocurrir porque
el sistema no tiene solución estas dos
rectas o las rectas que estas ecuaciones
representan tienen exactamente la misma
pendiente sin embargo su ordenada al
origen es diferente si las graficar amos
de hecho vamos a hacer un bosquejo
rápido aquí aquí tenemos el eje y aquí
tenemos el eje x este es el eje y este
es el eje x esta primera recta tiene una
ordenada al origen de 7 podemos ubicarlo
aquí déjame ponerlo un poco más abajo
aquí está un orden al origen de 100 y
sus pendientes de menos un cuarto podría
verse algo como esto así se podría ver
esta primera recta la segunda recta que
voy a graficar en rosa menos un cuarto
de x 120 su ordenada el origen se
ubicaría aproximadamente ahí en 120 y
tiene la misma pendiente que la recta
anterior menos un cuarto se vería
- así las rectas son paralelas nunca se
intersectan no hay parejas de puntos xy
ya que cumplan con las dos ecuaciones
otra manera de considerar esto sería
eliges una x arbitraria la multiplicas
por menos un cuarto le suma 100 y vas a
obtener el valor de iu pero la ecuación
de abajo establece que si al mismo valor
de x lo multiplicas por menos un cuarto
y le suman 120 vas a obtener el mismo
valor de y bien pero eso sólo puede ser
verdad si 100 y 120 fueran el mismo
número pero no son el mismo número no es
posible encontrar una solución del
sistema estas dos rectas no que se van a
interceptar pues tienen exactamente la
misma pendiente